i think men need to grow their balls
back
men are
men are just wimps these days
i'm here at the conference for masculine
excellence and we're talking to guys
about what they need to do in order to
become a better man let's talk
masculinity
how do you think men can level up today
primarily i think taking accountability
there's so many guys that are either
giving excuses blaming other things that
they should be holding themselves
accountable for keep raising your
probabilities right and that's with
everything in business too right raise
your probabilities and then when the
home run comes
you know exactly what to do now you can
capitalize a lot of men lack in the
areas of physical health and physical
fitness
and that's where i come in and that's
who i embody and this is what i commit
myself to
and i always say
true true wealth is health men need to
level up by just hustling going after it
you do are not a complainer exactly man
put some action one of the things i
always say is you could either spend
your time or invest your time choice is
yours make sure you invest it do
everything with confidence believe in
yourself if you put your mind to it you
could do it i mean i'm all the way out
here i'm only 19. they just need to stop
being so lazy they need to they need to
grind like it's all about the grind and
just working putting yourself out there
seeking opportunities like if you're
just sitting in your mom's basement
eating cheetos all day playing video
games you're not gonna get anywhere so
that's not what life's about
young men level up um don't get
caught up in the scene of ignorance and
you know surround yourself with with
people that are going to bring you up
you know what i'm saying that's true
your network is your net worth exercise
reason being because exercise creates
discipline and it creates consistency
and girls love muscles like let's be
real and also go ahead and flex bro i
mean i i didn't want to have to do this
but go ahead and flex on go ahead
we're doing a tricep y'all
okay
what area were you looking to most
improve while you're here
uh
meeting more like-minded individuals all
aspects i'm money and muscles primarily
i wanted to work on game mainly in
networking and getting to meet a lot of
these guys and ideas with business and
entrepreneurship as well and obviously
we all want to get up our game i need up
my game you know what i'm saying but i
didn't want to make this trip all about
women and getting and just getting women
i really need to like make this more
focused on you know me and develop
because once you improve everything else
will come with that it's still tough
walking up to girls and just talking to
them out here in uh miami it's a little
bit easier because that's what they're
out here for honestly to be honest it's
just it's just great to be here with all
with all you entertainment just look in
the network
you know how they say your network is
your net worth
how should men
conduct themselves with women today do
you handle yourself based on her
reaction if she spashes out you out we
don't do it based on based on what they
say because they'll be like i'll leave
you and i'll take everything and i'm
taking the kids and i'm taking the dog
but we don't give
i think men need to grow their balls
back
men are
men are just wimps these days and like i
used to be like that is if you don't set
boundaries with
the women that come into your life we
want to like give the resources give the
time and the attention you're going to
suck yourself dry being accountable and
being confident and true to yourself
you
create an aura around yourself and
ladies are all about the vibe the energy
men should not be oblivious
to the game
they shouldn't be oblivious to the game
uh there's what does that mean exactly a
lot of men typically think women are
sugar and spice and everything nice
they're running laps around us they're
attaining a lot more sexual interactions
than with us they understand how to
somewhat manipulate men
to their to their benefit one of the
best phrases i heard in this in this
space is a men lead women follow so you
got to be a leader you got to be in
charge of your life have all your ducks
in a row so when that
woman comes into your life she's going
to get on your program men lead women
follow through are only fans girls wifey
material absolutely not absolutely not
hell not no
no
recreational use only absolutely not i
would never wipe them up rock around
with them for a little while wifing nope
she's getting naked for a camera she
belonged to the streets
cannot wife these girls man whoever's
watching this you just got to stay away
from them if she's giving me some money
man you can show your titties you can
show your blue
i'm down with it just give me some of
the money what is wifey material and
what's the reason they're not because
when you think of a wife you think of
somebody that's somewhat conservative
someone that is exclusive for you but
the minute she starts talking anything
about marriage or whatever it's like of
course not honey she's going she's going
to be a reflection of you and and if
she's posting herself nude online that's
a reflection of you that's a reflection
of your leadership she's exposing her
body to multiple men or she's sleeping
around with multiple men
and i'm wiping that
so no is there anything that sticks out
to you that has really resonated with
you everything anything you talk
business is a tax write-off you can go
talk about business for like five
minutes and write it as a tax write-off
so being completely candid with your
approach like just going up to them and
like hey i just saw you i think you're
beautiful i had i wouldn't be able to
live with myself if i didn't say
something to you you got a lot of
confidence for a 24 year old um
and maybe it's the singing voice i don't
know i don't know here we are again
[Laughter]
boom letting go man like your inner
demons those shits are holding you back
and uh there's been a couple things that
have been on my head and maybe a little
bit of weight on my shoulders just an
area where uh men like-minded men we can
socialize uh we don't have many areas
that besides the barber shop maybe an
uncle's house or you know a cookout or a
barbecue or whatnot but just for men
from different walks of life to be able
to come to one area and communicate with
each other that's great so i wouldn't
want to miss that so here are my final
thoughts these guys are all here to
improve it's all about self-improvement
they're not here because they're women
haters or they're bashing women or
they're misogynists none of that what
they are is trying to become the best
versions of themselves and there ain't
nothing wrong with that respect
[Music]